Thank you for coming.
I want to let you know that this is a coming of age memoir,
so it's like don't really know much about my father's business life just in case
anybody wants to get up and go like,
oh,
um,
this memoir took me a long time to write.
It's probably,
I'd probably memorize generally or artistic projects.
My guess is they often take a long time,
but it took me a while because in the very beginning I found myself,
um,
sort of disappearing on the pages.
And this is a,
this is a coming of age memoir about a girl,
me growing up in the eighties and nineties in,
um,
silicon and you know,
California,
northern California,
Silicon Valley,
um,
and against the backdrop of a complicated family.
And,
um,
so it was problematic if I wasn't showing up on the pages,
I think.
So some of the scenes would be kind of good.
They'd have my parents,
they'd have a little bit of action.
I had to figure out,
you have to write a scene.
It turns out if you're going to write a memoir,
I could write,
but I wrote and wrote essays.
And if you write an essay for this long,
this is a 400 page book,
you sort of lose everyone after page 10,
I guess.
Um,
because it's so condensed.
So instead,
um,
I had to learn to write scenes,
which mean that I'm giving you,
I'm letting you live in the moments of my past,
I guess.
Um,
and uh,
but I was disappearing in them and which,
and they were so,
so the stakes,
the stakes of writing this memoir,
I felt kind of high because I think that the last thing I wanted to do was be
this,
um,
be a person,
the child of a celebrity essentially,
and be writing a memoir because celebrity memoir like cringe.
Um,
and,
but I,
I felt,
I guess that there was a kind of quality of disappearing in my own life and that
if I would write this book,
I could write other books after,
but I couldn't write those other books until I kind of solved this disappearing
issue and this shame issue.
It's almost like,
um,
you know,
in high school English when you have to like identify the themes of different
books.
And even though this is a nonfiction book,
when I kind of condensed it down to its essence,
there was a theme and it was a kind of question of illegitimacy did I have a
right to stand on the ground,
my own story?
Why did I have a right to sort of exist?
Um,
and so in that sense,
even though I'm saying it rather dramatically,
I guess it's kind of universal because I think that's a more common question.
Um,
so what happened?
The,
the fix for the disappearance I think was that I,
um,
one of the inspirations that I read Tobias Wolfe's this boy's life and he,
I noticed that the more it's a memoir and I noticed that the more sort of
naughty and devious and bad young was,
the more I totally loved him.
So I was like,
oh,
okay.
Um,
so I have to,
so I started to access my character through noticing where I wasn't,
where I was,
where I did things that were kind of shameful.
And then as I wrote them,
the scenes were pretty good because they had life to them.
And so then I guess in that way I sort of began to appear on the pages.
Um,
so I'll start with,
um,
I'll redo it from a,
a little bit of the beginning of the book.
This is a sort of am terribly embarrassing story,
which happened obviously,
um,
of like noticing that I was taking things.
Um,
so like many of the stories in this book,
I thought,
Oh God,
I can't include it.
But then ultimately it's in here.
Three months before he died,
I began to steal things from my father's house.
I wandered around barefoot and slipped objects into my pockets.
I took blush toothpaste to chipped finger bowls and sell it on blue,
a bottle of nail Polish,
a pair of Warren Patent leather ballet slippers and four faded white pillow
cases,
the color of old teeth.
After stealing each item,
I felt sated.
I promised myself that this would be the last time,
but soon the urge to take something else would arrive again.
Like thirst.
I tiptoed into my father's room,
careful to step over the creaky floorboard at the entrance.
This room had been his study when he could still climb the stairs,
but he slept here.
Now it was cluttered with books and mail and bottles of medicine.
Glass apples would an apples awards and magazines and stacks of paper that were
framed prints by his Sui of twilight and sunset at Temple's,
a patch of pink light stretched out on a wall beside him.
He was propped up in bed wearing shorts.
His legs were bare,
and then his arms bent up like a grasshoppers.
Hey,
lease.
He said Seg,
you ramp a chaise stood beside him.
He'd been around recently.
When I came to visit a short Brazilian man with sparkling Brown eyes,
the rim,
pushpay was a Buddhist monk with a scratchy voice who were brown robes over a
round belly.
We call him by his title to Benton holy men,
where sometimes born in the west.
Now in places like Brazil,
to me,
he didn't seem wholly,
he wasn't distant or inscrutable near Rasa,
black canvas bag of nutrients,
hummed with a motor and a pump.
The tube disappearing somewhere under my father's sheets.
It's a good idea to touch his feet.
The ramp.
Shay said putting his hands around my father's foot in the bed like this.
I didn't know if the foot touching was supposed to be for my father or for me or
for both of us.
Okay.
I said and took his other foot and it's thick sock.
Even though it was strange watching my father's face because when he Winston
pain or anger,
it looked similar to when he started to smile.
That feels good.
My father said closing his eyes.
I glanced at the chest of drawers beside him and at the shelves on the other
side of the room for objects I wanted.
Even though I knew I wouldn't dare steal something out right in front of him
while he slept,
I wandered through the house looking for,
I didn't know what a nurse sat on the couch in the living room,
her hands on her lap,
listening for my father to call out for help.
The house was quiet.
The sound's muffled.
The white painted brick walls were dimpled like cushions in the cabinet of the
half bath near the kitchen where there used to be a tattered copy of the
Bhagavad Gita.
I found a bottle of expensive rose facial mist with the door closed the light
out sitting on the toilet seat.
I sprayed it up into the air and closed my eyes.
The mist fell around me cool and wholly as an a forest or an old stone church,
there was also a tube of silver lip gloss with a brush at one end and a twisting
mechanism at the other.
That release liquid into the center of the brush.
I had to have it.
I stuffed the lip gloss into my pocket to take back to the one bedroom apartment
in Greenwich village that I shared with my boyfriend,
where I knew as much as I have ever known anything that this tube of lip gloss
would complete my life between avoiding the housekeeper,
my brother and sisters,
and my stepmother around the house so I wouldn't be caught stealing things or
hurt when they didn't acknowledge me or reply to my hellos and spraying myself
in the dark and bathroom to feel less like I was disappearing because inside the
falling missed,
I had a sense of having an outline again,
making efforts to see my sick father in his room began to feel like a burden,
a nuisance.
For the past year,
I've visited every weekend,
every other month or so,
I'd given up on the possibility of a grand reconciliation,
the kind in movies,
but I kept coming anyway before I said goodbye,
I went to the bathroom to miss one more time.
The spray was natural,
which meant that over the course of a few minutes,
it no longer smells sharp like roses,
but fitted and stinky like a swamp.
Although I didn't know it at the time.
As I came into his room,
he was getting into a standing position.
I watched him gather both of his legs and one arm twist himself 90 degrees by
pushing against the headboard with the other arm and then use both arms to hoist
his own legs over the edge of the bed and onto the floor.
When we hugged,
I could feel his vertebrae,
his ribs,
he smelled musty like medicine,
sweat,
I'll be back soon.
I said,
we detached and I started walking away.
Lease.
Yeah,
you smell like a toilet.
Um,
it was the rose spray and this is one scene of many.
I actually returned all of the things I did,
but this is not a story of,
of theft.
Um,
although I did like the idea of theft is a,
a kind of metaphor for what I was doing.
There's a terror when you're writing a memoir because even if you want to write
about yourself,
you find that you have just yourself,
um,
you find that you necessarily pull all these other people up into your net.
And so you have a responsibility to do the best job with them.
You can to be kind and to be honest,
and to try to capture some of their character as it at least as it relates to
your own life.
But sometimes,
um,
you weren't able to capture necessarily the fullness of everyone's character.
Um,
you're capturing how they're interesting to you and you're using them in a
certain way to tell an emotional story of yourself.
But I did get an email once from my mother's,
um,
ex boyfriend and the email was titled Correction.
And I thought,
oh no.
And I went into it and,
and he said,
um,
that I had,
that there was a person named Ron and my book and perhaps I had described him,
you know,
and,
and that this person named Ron and my book had many similarities to this
boyfriend who was also named Ron in that they both worked for NASA and that they
both had dated my mother at a certain point.
Um,
but that I described this person who clearly wasn't him as,
um,
uh,
sort of having hair tufted on the sides,
like a clown and having,
um,
having a sort of,
totally shiny bald head and walking with his feet splayed out and I'm having
lips,
like a fish.
I thought,
Oh God.
And so he said,
I've,
I've attached to photograph of myself for further reference.
Um,
if you do want to describe me.
And he had a picture of Fabio.
But then I thought,
oh no,
I have,
I just grabbed this man who was quite wonderful in this sort of,
not very flattering way.
And then I thought back on that scene and I realized,
oh,
it was because I was meeting him for the very first time.
He just started dating my mother and I felt possessive of my mother and I wasn't
sure I liked him so much.
Um,
and so that's why I had described him that way.
Now that I've already described myself in a sort of compromised way,
the only way I felt like I had permission to describe other people the way that
they were,
and with all of their eccentricities,
as I had to describe my own.
The other thing I can say right now,
I'm just worried that in my scatterbrainedness I'll forget later,
is something like,
I'm trying to give people the chance to have their own story within the pages of
my story.
So I think different people take different things from this book.
They have different relationships with their parents and,
and they had different coming of age stories and it's been sort of a victory to
me,
this,
this idea that I brought up people's paths for themselves because they've come
up to me and readings and they've said,
oh,
that feels exactly like me.
I'm a single mother.
Or they've said,
oh,
my father was like that.
He would make jokes like that or he was difficult like that.
And I've noticed that if you read a book at a certain point in your life,
maybe a book that you love and then you wait 10 years and you read it again,
it's almost like it's a totally different book.
And I have a feeling it's not the book that changed.
I think it's that we continue to continuously change and then,
and then art hopefully reflects our own changes back to us.
So I think that it's sort of a difficult thing because this book that I wrote
about my family is now everyone else's book.
It's not mine anymore.
And I have to kind of release it and say whatever you get out of it,
it's what you're supposed to get out of it because it's your book.
Now of course that's a little difficult because it's my family and sometimes I
want to say no,
that's not what I meant.
Um,
but that doesn't really matter anymore.
But without further due the Ron story,
since she's become interested in Ron,
she no longer paid attention to me as a stately.
I thought she no longer consulted the itching.
She was half absent with happiness,
the same slight smile on her lips that she went when she ran up the hill to get
the prickly pear.
It was between boyfriends,
between the loneliness and despair that followed one and the lift that began the
next where I hope to stay forever.
She and I,
the only team,
the real couple on the night of the date,
Ron arrived on time.
She was leaning over the bathroom sink doing her makeup.
When he knocked,
I ran to open the door.
I saw right away that Ron wasn't a hippie.
He was bald with hair tufted on the side like a clowns and had wide bushy
eyebrows,
glasses,
rimmed with gold and large swollen lips like a fish.
He looked clean and smelled of soap and detergent.
Hello?
I said I'm Lisa.
My Mom's getting ready.
Nice to meet you.
He said,
holding out his hand.
He followed me into the living room.
I noticed that as he walked his feet splayed out dramatically to either side.
My mother called from the bathroom.
I'll be out in a minute.
As we pass the bookshelf.
I reached for the album of photographs of my birth.
This was unplanned.
It surprised even me,
one armed jutting out as if I didn't have control of my limbs and pull it out of
its socket on the shelf.
I was seven years old at this point.
I'd asked her to get rid of this album many times.
She refused bringing it with us.
As we move from house to house,
that cover was made of Brown woven grasses and because it was old,
the grasses has started to fray at the edges.
To me to this hinted at the shame of the contents.
I suspected other children didn't have shameful books like this around in their
houses.
He and I sat down on the flowered couch beside each other.
I want to show you something I said,
just some photos of my mother and me.
I opened the book across my lap where he could see it.
My mother younger lying on a bed with long hair like dark water pooling around
her face.
These were the pictures of my birth in black and white with rounded corners.
She had what looked like a man's shirt,
buttoned around her chest and she was naked from the waist down with her legs
bent and open.
In the foreground of the photo,
I turned the page there I was emerging from between her glowing white legs like
a turtle rising up from a pond.
In the following picture is once I was out you could see my body wrinkled,
my face,
wax,
white,
asymmetrical and squished.
I felt revulsion and discussed and yet I continued to turn the pages.
I would not have known how to articulate it.
I wanted to discuss him the way I was disgusted to scare him away,
to show him who we were so that he might leave now rather than wait.
And here's more.
I said in my sweetest voice,
yes,
he said,
I see he made no motion to rise and run.
He sat glancing at the pages and then looking away as if distracted.
When my mother came out of the bathroom and saw us,
she snatched the album from my hands and stuck it back in its place on the
shelf,
giving me a furious look.
So I think one of the things also that I'm trying to do with this book is to get
so particular about my life that in some ways it gets universal so that people,
I think that the Steve Jobs thing can be quite distracting and people think,
oh my life must be so different.
But then when they read it,
it's not so different.
Everyone has,
usually people have complicated people that they love and they have,
um,
sort of bumps in the road of coming of age.
And I think in some ways the contrasts are quite high in this book in my story.
But the more I hear from other people and the more I,
you know,
and,
and because I know people and have friends and love people,
I know that people also have stories like this even if they don't have the same
degree of notoriety I guess.
But I had to have use people in my life that I loved to stand in for other
things.
And I was doing a reading,
actually at my old high school.
Everyone who is in this memoir was there.
It was kind of terrifying.
And including my ex boyfriend,
my high school boyfriend who I wrote some things about him.
And I think,
um,
you know,
he's certainly a more interesting person than on these pages and these pages.
He's kind of like in relation to me.
Um,
but what I was thinking about his character in the book is that he kind of
stands for,
he stands for California.
Um,
falling in love with him is a way of explaining the bay area where I grew up.
And I'm sure lots of you,
I guess,
I imagine lots of you have been to the bay area,
um,
because Google and I'm actually,
I guess Google started in the garage of my journalism teacher.
Um,
so,
um,
and she,
she ran the paper and my high school and it hadn't started yet.
It was a twinkle in someone's eye I guess.
Um,
but it was just about to start in these pages,
although I didn't know.
But anyway,
this isn't a story about Google.
This is a story about me.
So I,
um,
so this is the story of,
of high school and the bay area.
And I was writing this book from the cold wilds of Brooklyn and imagining
sunshine and imagining air that had perfume in it of Eucalyptus and Bay Laurel
and you know,
the grass is on the hills and it was a nice place to live for a long time.
Now I'm going to have to actually go back to Brooklyn and live in Brooklyn.
Um,
but it was a nice way to time travel,
spend time with my young parents and sort of travel through space and be in the
bay area again,
which is so beautiful.
On the way home from another visit to my school to the school,
my father suggested that we stop at Palo Alto high school pally for short,
just to see what it was like.
It was late in the afternoon and school was out for few minutes.
We walked around the empty quad.
Many of the buildings look like bunkers.
I felt uncomfortable as if we were trespassing,
but then we heard music coming from somewhere and we followed it over to where a
tall boy was standing beside the door where the music was coming from.
I was too shy to speak,
but my father asked,
what's going on in here?
And the boy said it's the paper.
And we peered into the room.
There were lots of people inside working on computers and lounging on beanbags
and I thought if I did decide to go here,
I'd work on the paper too.
You know what's great about going to school nearby your house?
My father asked as we left.
You can walk to it like I did and if you walk a lot over the course of time,
you get to see the seasons change.
He said it in the same slow way.
He spoke of beautiful women,
but walking to school didn't sound very romantic to me.
Nonetheless,
I go to the school and now I'm in my senior year.
In my senior year at Pally,
I was elected to the position of editor and chief of the paper.
One day in the middle of the week,
there were technical problems.
The computer systems crashed.
The screens went dark.
The printer became inaccessible.
If the computer is no longer operated and when not reboot,
days of work would be lost.
All our carefully designed pages,
Josh,
his dirty blonde hair,
the color of a Sand Dune,
Warren in a thick ponytail laid down on the floor to inspect and arrange the
wires.
The rest of us mold in a daze of terror and tragedy.
Do you want to come?
He asked me about a trip to his house to get a missing cord.
I noticed Josh more closely now dimples when he smiled wide shoulders beneath
flannel shirts.
He was shy and friendly and had loose complicated handwriting like the bouncing
string of a kite.
Sure.
I said not knowing then that he lived in Portola Valley 20 minutes away.
He seemed to me sloppy,
too relaxed shambolic he could fix computers,
but he was disorganized for getting to do his assignments for Mrs. Pause English
class.
Whereas I was meticulous.
Greg Grade Grubber,
he never arrived anywhere on time and he was hopeless with a calendar,
wouldn't have his homework and scramble to do it in the minutes before class.
Later I would find out that he was taking applied mathematics and differential
equations at Stanford and he would be admitted to college at Stanford and Mit,
so he was clearly fine.
He drove a used 83 Toyota supra and incandescent teal with a pink sign wave
painted along both sides.
Sorry about the paint job.
He said as we got in,
he bought it used from a female physicist in Livermore.
He had nice hands on the steering wheel.
His room had a mattress on the floor and a window looking out to a yard and the
forest.
There were papers and books strewn around,
a stack of stereo equipment and headphones.
It was large enough to seem empty and cluttered at the same time.
He found the cord and we left.
On the way back,
we turned onto Arastradero,
a two lane road rough and patched.
That wound beside a nature preserve.
I'm going to show you a secret.
He said,
hold on.
The speed limit was 25 he began to accelerate.
We advance toward a blind corner where the road rose up and then disappeared a
hill on one side,
drop on the other.
The road curled back on itself around the hill,
out of sight.
Another car might be advancing toward us and smash into us at the bend.
A family of deer might be walking across.
He continued to build speed.
Shifting up.
Third,
fourth,
fifth.
The car rumbled and wind.
Are you sure you should be?
Don't worry.
He yelled.
I've done it before.
My mother sometimes said,
there are guardian angels just for teenagers.
Oh,
help me,
God of teenagers.
I thought,
Oh God of teenagers.
Hold on.
He yelled,
the car scraped.
The gear is saying,
I grip the top of the seat belt in one hand,
the door handle and the other.
He shifted again,
peeled around the bright blind curve and then we flew.
It was because of the uneven road,
a raised portion followed by a long dip downhill.
If you got up enough speed,
you could catch the lip of the up and fly over the concavity through the dots of
light cast by the row of emerald trees and bushes growing alongside the road for
me,
the flight unleaded,
the town there were hidden places of freedom and he knew them and then we're
dating
sometimes in the late afternoon after school.
During the weeks when we were not producing the newspaper.
Josh and I went to Windy Hill preserve up above skyline hills,
white and yellow and soft like the humps of camels on one side more hills like a
blanket thrown out into the wind all the way that the Pacific Ocean,
the town was a miniature below us silent and still except for the singing
rasping wind that flattened the tall grasses,
a clear day,
too much to take in the glassy era and the feeling of great freedom and grace.
The world opening.
I look north and I could see San Francisco sparkling in the distance.
It was both close and far away.
Something to do with the angle of this hill to those hills,
the refraction of the light.
That's how I felt about my parents now that Josh was around,
not that I didn't worry about my mom or my father or what would happen when he
realized that I was really leaving for college,
I was simply hovering above it all so it didn't pinch or press.
Now Josh was the one who drove me to doctor's appointments or between houses.
He did not keep a calendar,
forgot about work assignments and Miss Dentist's appointments and other
appointments,
but never the ones with me.
I was protected in tight inside his tail supra after the spring rains when the
grasses came up out of the clause of dirt under the oak and eucalyptus trees
around Stanford for Radian fas like whiskers,
stripes of gold,
light in long ribbons.
I thought,
this is my town.
I walked home afterschool and notice the seasons change.
Before this.
It was my father's town or my mother's town or the town where I had been placed
by accident and shifted around.
Now I was in love and the land was dimensional and heavy and particulate.
It belonged to me.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
thanks.
That was awesome.
Thank you for the readings that they were really great.
Um,
when you think about your dad,
how would you describe him?
It's hard to sum it up so quickly.
Very human.
I would say.
It was interesting.
I mean I was talking about time traveling.
One thing you get to do when you're writing a memoir is you get to go and hang
out.
At least I did.
You get to go and hang out with your parents when they're younger than you are
now.
Um,
so you get to notice that they're human.
And one thing that I noticed was that,
so my father wasn't really around when I was very little.
MMM.
I was unexpected,
unwanted.
Um,
and my parents were both so young and um,
his career trajectory was just just beginning then and really starting to ramp
up as far as I understand.
So,
um,
he wasn't around and then at a certain point he must've made a pretty clear
decision to come back and be a part of my life.
And I think for me at the time,
and you will see in the book,
um,
it was very awkward.
We wanted to get to know each other,
but I think he was very young and didn't really know how to be with kids.
And I had been dreaming of him for so long that it was like I wanted him to
arrive on the scene where the real Bam and he was in some ways the dream father
in a sense of being the father.
You dream about when you don't have one?
Um,
he was a famous and he was rich and he was incredibly charismatic and he was
handsome and he drove a Porsche.
And so it was kind of like this realer than real,
larger than life arrival.
But in another way it was disappointing because he was so awkward.
There were these long pauses.
And,
um,
I went back as a part of this book and watched this next presentation.
Um,
it was the introduction to the next,
I think at Davies Symphony Hall in San Francisco.
And I had already written about it,
but,
um,
but I wanted,
I wanted to watch the presentation because I want it to make sure that what I'd
remembered was correct.
And,
um,
I'm not really a Steve jobs completionist so I don't really watch his old
presentations.
Um,
I was there at some of them and the other ones,
you know,
he was my father or not this figure.
Um,
but I got myself to watch the presentation.
I'd remembered looking at him from the perspective of a daughter and him being
kind of amazing and larger than life.
And then when I watched the presentation again on Youtube,
he was incredible.
I was like,
oh wow.
He really was incredible.
This wasn't just the perspective of a daughter.
Um,
he seemed so at ease in front of so many people.
And so,
um,
so I guess this just kind of a terrible word,
but so relatable,
so simple and human at the same time as being so sparkling and incredible and
so set against our personal interactions.
When we were getting to know each other,
we were,
um,
you know,
the first time I was going to stay at his house overnight because my mother was
taking a class and I went to his company and waited for him for a while.
Then we got in his car,
um,
and his amazing Porsche and drove to his mansion and the whole drive,
he didn't say a word.
So,
and at the time I thought,
you know,
maybe it was something I did or maybe,
um,
if I had been more of a conversationalist or maybe he was mad at me and I
realize looking back as an adult spending time with this young awkward man that
he actually just was kind of doing his best and he was quite human.
So,
um,
it was wonderful to have certain revelations like that to let myself,
to give myself the permission to understand,
um,
who he might've been as a father and a person and where he might've been coming
from,
um,
as,
uh,
complicated and incomplete person as we all are.
I hope that answers your question again.
I don't,
I,
I'm the last person to talk about his work life,
right?
So I feel like when you look back at your childhood,
a lot of people have patchy memories or may have remembered something
incorrectly that then somebody tells you the story later,
an older adult that may have been there.
So I'm wondering if you had more of those revelations as you were writing about
them,
things that you thought happened a certain way and then as you started to
describe him,
you realize actually that's not at all what happened.
Did you have moments like that and what was one that was interesting?
I'm sure I did have moments like that.
Um,
so what happens is it's really hard to remember so many things from your life.
And I wasn't sure at the beginning I had enough memory to write a whole book
about my childhood.
It's a coming of age book,
so it ends when I leave for college and I was terrified.
But it turns out when you start to sit down and think and work at it and write
something about writing also helps you get one story.
And then another one connects to that story and then another one connects.
And after a while you have a whole constellation of stories.
And if you kind of pull this end,
this end kind of trembles.
So that I wrote,
I probably wrote seven books for this book.
Um,
stories that helped me get to a place,
but that in the end weren't necessary,
didn't merit inclusion.
And I'm looking for the,
I'm looking for the stories in my life that stand for several things.
Um,
maybe stories that are,
that are,
are kind of metaphors as well.
And there was one to hide.
My father used to always say,
lease,
you're going to remember this.
Um,
and I thought,
what am I,
the record keeper.
Um,
but also I thought,
Oh God,
I hope I remember what,
why would I remember this particular moment?
Because some of the moments were very poignant perhaps for him and they weren't
for me.
And so I didn't quite understand what was going on.
And there was one moment when we were on a vacation in Hawaii,
I think I was maybe nine,
and he'd been,
especially when I looked at this book and researched it,
I understood he'd been wavering back and forth about his paternity.
It had been proven by a DNA test,
but he's still was saying he wasn't my father in public and to other people and
private.
Um,
but there was this moment when we were in Hawaii and I do remember him sort of
pointing out body parts and saying,
look,
we have the same this and we have the same this.
And I remember his,
his,
he wanted to sort of sit there for a while and his arm around my waist kind of
felt like a seat seatbelt because I wanted to run and leap and jump to the
desserts table.
And I thought,
why is he keeping me this heaviness?
Um,
and I talked with his ex girlfriend Tina,
and she remembered that time too with a little more clarity.
And she also was telling me that he was even saying to her that he wasn't
necessarily my father and it was at that moment because she was there too,
that she saw that he was kind of claiming me.
And so I had remembered some part of that moment,
um,
from my child's perspective.
But the full import of that scene was not apparent until I went back and did
some research and understood kind of what was really going on.
And it was wonderful to be able to layer my childhood memories and feelings and
desires and longings with the woman that I am now who knows so much more about
people and who can understand more of what's going on.
Um,
it was like I could sort of keep my child self company.
so the times,
you know,
I don't know if it happens for you guys,
but like sometimes things happen,
New York kid and you don't know what they mean.
And so it's those things that you keep and preserve and bring forward into your
adulthood.
Um,
maybe because you hope at some point you'll have the information and the wisdom
and the knowledge to be able to sort of open up those mysteries and make sense
of them later.
And so the process of writing really was a process of opening up all these long
closed boxes and seeing what was inside and sometimes what was inside was kind
of running the run of the mill story.
And sometimes what was inside was more than I had anticipated.
Um,
and changed my own perspective of my past.
And I guess I do hope to do that for other people reading the book.
Um,
also I hope to maybe,
um,
change other people's perspective or deepen their own awareness or their
memories of their own past.
I think it's definitely happened for people who grew up in California because,
um,
they're like the smells,
you know,
cause I have so many smells in this book,
maybe too many smells.
Um,
but I think childhood also has,
um,
a lot of these mysteries in it.
There's like a,
there's a thing you do as a kid,
I guess you use anything you've got because you don't really have much.
Um,
so remembering all the times I kind of subtly and not so subtly kind of tried to
use my father's fame to prop myself up.
How embarrassing is that?
Um,
and then,
you know,
trying to forgive that young person for or,
or be able to chuckle at the young person for doing whatever she could do and
being scrappy.
Yes.
So another funny connection,
your journalism teacher,
I believe as turbo Chesky who's a,
one of his daughters is a youtube CEO.
Another daughter was,
was married to Sergey Brin,
I think,
you know,
for a little while.
To what extent were these connections to the rest of Silicon Valley,
that connectedness part of your life?
Google was beginning in her garage.
I think around the time I was graduating or maybe just about when I went to
college and I had just about no idea.
So amazing things can be happening around you and you can not know about them
even if even if you're right in the epicenter of them.
Um,
or maybe I'm,
you know,
I don't think anyone particularly new.
Um,
so yes,
that was watch and I had an event,
I was saying I had an event at my high school with watch the other day and
everyone,
almost everyone in the memoir was there,
which I can tell you is kind of terrifying.
Um,
but I'm relating to my story as,
um,
the story of a girl with a father and a mother growing up in California at that
time.
Um,
not as the story of a titan.
Nora have a,
um,
silicon valley guru.
I get to talk about how silicon valley was,
um,
because I lived it,
but,
um,
I certainly was not a part of the business aspect,
I guess that's interesting in its own way.
I remember coming back in college and um,
that was during the first.com boom.
I think and noticing that like every other car was a Ferrari and there were lots
of high heels and I'd never seen high yields in Palo Alto before that.
So I was like,
wow,
what's happened to my place?
And even,
and now going back of course it's vastly different.
Um,
but this is,
um,
I think this is more of a story everyone can relate with even though it has,
dramatic ups and downs.
Yes.
You've talked about how you looked at your father and you are trying to kind of
from the outside learn how he was feeling about being your father.
Like the thing with the arm and I was wondering if you've ever actually had an
open conversation with him about this.
If you ever asked him why it was so difficult for him to accept that he is your
father?
That's a good question.
Um,
it was hard to talk with him about things like that.
He said that he wasn't so good at communicating and,
um,
there was a kind of wonderful moment,
the end of the book,
I had been waiting for this Hollywood moment.
He was so sick and I'm waiting for some sort of moment of reconciliation.
Um,
and of course I knew I was an idiot because when do you get those moments that
are in the movies,
right?
When the person says,
I'm sorry,
or I understand how you felt,
or,
but still I was waiting for it.
So I kept on returning home and I think that's why I was sort of pilfering these
objects,
um,
because I felt things weren't complete.
Um,
but I couldn't really get that conversation out of him.
And I was terrified when,
when we had talked about it earlier,
he had said things like,
you know,
just move on or,
um,
he said at some point he was sorry,
and he said he loved me.
Um,
but it somehow wasn't enough for this,
what felt like a kind of tidal wave of grief actually,
um,
that we'd miss each other for so long.
So when he was dying,
he,
um,
I went back a month before and finally we had a kind of amazing moment where he
said,
I really owe you one over and over again,
and it's such an odd phrase.
I owe you one.
Um,
he hadn't really said it before and Kevin,
I'm wondering what is the one?
Um,
and he was also sad because,
um,
he hadn't really spent the time,
he said,
and the problem with dying is,
I guess it's a kind of like a final end.
So if you haven't spent the time before that happens,
then,
um,
then it's too late,
you know?
Um,
so,
so that,
that felt very meaningful.
Like,
okay,
we're on the same page.
We missed something here.
Uh,
and I wished it had happened earlier because it would have been nice to be
friends.
It would have been nice to have a feeling that he had been sort of unburdened of
this feeling earlier so that we were on the same page because we actually really
liked each other and had some great times together.
He was also really funny and he was enjoyable to be with a lot.
We had a lot of fun on our skates and it felt like it was very lucky in some
ways that I lived with him during high school,
during high school.
Because even though as you will see in the book,
I am full on in the midst of adolescent angst,
um,
I realized if we hadn't lived together then we wouldn't have gotten to know each
other as well as we did.
Um,
and that contains its own kind of resolution because I guess if you know someone
more as a person,
um,
their flaws become more understandable and they perhaps become less personal.
I guess I did feel,
um,
and I write about this in the book,
but I did feel that I've been hearing about sometimes people imitate my father
by imitating his wardrobe or,
or they imitate maybe some of the ways he could be caustic and sharp and
difficult and sometimes cruel.
And,
um,
from my experience,
the
sensitive that he had had an extremely sensitive part,
um,
very dear,
very kind,
very simple,
very caring.
And it was from that part as far as I could tell by knowing some of his work
colleagues.
And by knowing him to the degree that I did,
it was from that part from which he created.
And so
I wondered if perhaps some of the imitations of the caustic part,
um,
if that part was the part that was protecting this ultra sensitive core.
And so if the imitations in that sense are a bit misguided,
give him that you and your dad didn't,
he didn't fully accept you as his kid until you were a little bit older.
Um,
how did you deal with that reconciliation from your perspective,
both when you were a kid and then as an adult when you had more perspective?
I think this book is going to answer so many of your questions,
um,
but in a subtle way.
So,
um,
I think,
I thought I had gotten over it sort of because we had had a lot of good times
together and he'd apologized and we liked each other and we used to tease each
other.
But then certain funny things kept on happening.
Like I was enraged that he wouldn't get a couch.
We had chairs,
we had places to sit.
Um,
but my mother and I had been sort of nomadic.
We'd been a little bit rootless,
we'd been searching for home,
and so we didn't really have a couch.
We'd sort of stolen,
taken one from him at some point.
And then Carter,
this sort of horrible couch around.
But this feeling that he owed me a couch was so profound.
So I would complain bitterly about the couches and I felt so sad about it.
And so deeply owed and so enraged,
disproportionate to what a couch actually is.
And I think that my sense of grief about having lost him became blame,
became anger and what sort of attached itself to these odd objects.
Um,
so in that sense,
I think it took a while to understand to get under the,
under the skin of my own,
um,
my own sort of strange frustrations and understand that loss might've been at
the root of them,
which was kind of another revelation of writing the book.
Oh,
right.
Why was I so fixated on the couch?
Oh,
right.
Because I hadn't had a father during all that time.
I don't really tell you this in the book,
but I think it,
it becomes kind of clear.
MMM.
Did you want to ask a question too?
Sure.
My interest I guess is,
uh,
do you have technology and use technology in your life?
Like do you have an iPhone or do you have an android device?
There's lots of folks here that work on,
I'm a competitive product.
I am as a new mom,
do you have a plan for how you're going to deal with technology with your,
with your kids?
First of all,
I have an iPhone and I'm slightly bitter because the new ones seemed to be so
large and I have the smallest hands and so they kind of,
um,
it kind of slips a bit.
Um,
so maybe I need to get an android and solve that.
No,
I can say that.
And I love the camera on the iPhone and I love,
and I wrote my book on an apple and I love it.
But when I was writing it was very difficult to interact with this sort of Insto
texting world while I was doing deeper work.
It would sort of pull me out of,
um,
profound thinking.
So I would leave my phone at a cafe down the street and I was actually dating at
the time,
which made it really made it really difficult to date,
um,
when you don't have a phone.
But I would leave it at a cafe and they would,
um,
they would hold it for me.
And which is so odd,
right?
For sometimes for days at a time,
um,
because sometimes you go to a hard place in your writing and you realize you're
writing really badly.
And it feels like if you look at your phone and you can text with your friends
or,
or you can look at some article that you've sort of solved the problem,
but in fact you've haven't,
you kind of have to sit with the misery,
the misery of your own bad sentences for a while.
They become good.
But they started bad because I didn't know where I was coming from.
So,
um,
so hiding away my phone was very useful and sort of turning off the Internet for
a while was useful.
So the relationship I have with my devices is close but intermittent.
And,
um,
and I've tried when I'm nursing,
and when I'm with my son not to be on the phone,
and me and our babysitter have talked about like trying not to do that so much
when we're with him.
Um,
because it feels as if you're,
you're giving someone concentrated attention,
but of course you're not.
Um,
and I find the easiest solution is to kind of get rid of it for his crying.
And he's like,
I'm sorry,
that's my son.
Uh,
um,
so I'm hoping for future books.
It's not so fraught that I'm able to put my phone in the other room and ignore
it for a while.
But I found with this book I had to either leave it at a cafe or later lock it
in a food addiction,
Xbox,
um,
for a time.
Um,
but you can get on Amazon actually.
probably other places too.
Um,
but,
uh,
so I wouldn't say love,
hate,
but intermittent and clothes maybe.
Yes.
So I was thinking about this,
you and your family,
especially your father had had been portrayed numerous times in like film and
television.
And have you paid attention to any of this?
It must be weird.
Like how do you feel about it?
Just in general thought
I sort of assiduously avoid it.
Um,
I haven't,
I have,
I didn't see the,
the Sorkin movie and I,
I didn't read the Isaacson biography and I
don't read the books about my phone.
I figure like there's a scene in peewee's big adventure.
My Dad and I used to watch that and they make a movie about peewee at the end of
his big adventure.
And Dottie,
his friend says,
peewee,
aren't you going to watch your movie?
And he says,
I don't have to.
Dottie,
I lived at,
so something like that.
But also I was working on a book and I thought,
you know,
sometimes you can look at a picture and it informs your own memory.
You stop remembering what you remember and you start remembering the picture.
And I felt it was very important to not interact with um,
other people's interpretations of my father's life with me as a kind of bit
character.
Um,
cause it was our already a courageous act to decide I got to be a main
character.
I mean I think people will sometimes pick up this book thinking that they're
getting a book about Steve Jobs and they will be plunged into the coming of age
Sagas of a girl,
which,
which I think is wonderful.
Maybe it's a book some people wouldn't normally buy.
Um,
but I'm actually finding men are liking it a lot too,
which I was hoping for and which surprises me,
you know,
because it is so specifically about a woman or a girl.
Um,
but yeah,
I kind of don't interact with them and I don't have difficulty avoiding press.
Like even during this book tour,
I've kind of had to keep my equanimity and the way I've done that as a by not
reading any reviews our press.
Um,
so because when I think of it,
I sort of get a pit in my stomach.
Um,
it's hard to be part of another person's narrative,
which is part of the reason I felt like heavy hearted about writing my own
narrative because other people would be a part of it.
Um,
and I've done the best I could with it.
and I think we do have,
we do have the right to,
to write our own stories or to come to terms with their own stories,
but we don't necessarily have the obligation to,
to participate in the stories of others.
I have three daughters and I'm pretty comfortable with like my own passion for
technology.
I don't really share much of that with them.
Um,
so I'm just kind of wondering,
like,
you having a father is very passionate about like what were your common grounds?
Like what,
what,
how did you connect with each other on like,
I mean,
cause we have our things we do because I know they're not interested in all of
my technology enthusiasm.
You like gadgets,
no mortgage,
no.
Yeah,
I think people are looking for connection and um,
love and humor from their parents and their fathers.
Um,
and the gadgets are such a,
there's such a means to something,
right?
They're not an end.
Um,
and they certainly don't replace human contact would be my thought.
so
my father was,
um,
when he was on his game,
totally delightful to hang out with because he was interested in curious about a
ton of things.
Um,
and I guess the way technology is the best from my perspective is that it can
help with that kind of curiosity and that kind of investigation,
but it doesn't replace curiosity or hanging out together or spending time
together.
And I think,
um,
in my experience of my father,
he was not an exception to that.
He was not,
he did not seem gadget obsessed.
Um,
he knew that,
um,
I wasn't,
you know,
going to talk with him for hours about the iPhone.
Um,
so we would take skates and talk about roses and talk about architecture and
talk about Fonts and talk about Palo Alto.
And he seemed very interested in those things.
And I guess interest and curiosity are infectious.
So I think you're doing great.
Awesome.
Thank you so much for coming.
Thank you.